I'm gonna sum up Breaking Bad for you
real fast Jessie where the hell are you
mr. white quit being such a dick man
[ __ ] there you go
that's the whole show Breaking Bad this
this is one of the best shows of all
time
if this show had a dick I would cite it
they would smoke a bowl of meth
afterwards no amount of words can
express my love and enthusiasm for this
show the way it starts off and then by
the time it ends I mean you got like two
completely different set of characters
by the end all these characters don't
just grow every season they evolve like
every episode I've seen a lot of shows
we're like yes the character involves
one season and then by like the next
they're back to pretty much being
themselves it's like the impact didn't
do much I'm gonna do my best to review
this show without giving away any
spoilers because let's face it if there
were spoilers it would it be straight to
the point
Bryan Cranston as Walter [ __ ] White I
hadn't [ __ ] that's not his real
middle name this show is just pure
brilliance at a whole of the caliber
they took a man in his early 50s who's
like a self-loathing little joe high
school chemistry teacher sounds so
boring but then he does exactly what the
show says he starts to break bad cuz
once homeboy is diagnosed with cancer
enough is enough mother [ __ ] you see
him break worse not just bad he gets
better throughout the seasons he falls
into a monster like by the time you get
to season five is especially the last
half which some of you are gonna be like
isn't that season six Ryan and to that I
say [ __ ] idiot like we're the last
half of season five you start to feel
like wait a minute is is Walt the bad
guy should we trust Walt's I guess my
point I'm trying to get it is you start
to wonder if you should you know be on
board with Walt they give us a character
to watch like the nicest most timid
human being evolved into Caucasian
Scarface it's so strange because they
challenged the audience to be on board
with a character like this wouldn't have
gotten away years ago you just he just
gets so
like the Michael Jackson song and the
worse he got the more hooked you became
you didn't stop liking him you just
thought he was more badass like that
notice in the first season they put most
of its focus on Walter White's as they
should have as any smart writer would do
but once we got into season two we
started to explore the supporting cast
even more an Aaron Paul as Jesse Pinkman
what the hell mr. White's I love this
guy I rewatched the whole series man
when I first saw the show I thought he
was gonna be some like annoying
douchebag cocky little [ __ ] whose
performance I would probably hate you
know like some piece of [ __ ] television
actor because I am that judgmental but
it's like in a heartbeat he starts to
win you over the role could have easily
been ruined seriously I don't mean this
in a bad way it's like he's not even
acting he's just that authentic from is
like paranoid mannerisms to his thuggish
attitude from his lack of knowledge to
what he happens to be knowledgeable
about his sense of humor but was trauma
all that [ __ ] man he embodies the role
you love the guy you root for him you
feel for him and it's so interesting to
watch like a partnership story evolved
into what it became by the last season
Tim a king of rings and a gun as Skyler
white Walter White's wife WWWE honestly
the first time I watched the show
[ __ ] hated this [ __ ]
I was definitely on Team Walter but
whenever we watch the show I saw how
brilliant her performance is just
psychologically the way this character
of balls until I got damaged emotionally
or oppressed human being who's
conflicted by love her her husband all
that resonates in her performance and
plus in the first season she's beautiful
to look at I would bang that pregnant
woman I didn't really find her trying to
win the other seasons but Wow
season one should have had to carry two
babies if you know what I mean I love
Dean Norris as Hank Schrader in the
first season they made in juice some
like typical law-enforcement guy nice
but tough who is packing a little bit of
extra weights and is bald just like
everyone else on the show but then they
gave him a lot more to do
even with his character you don't
suspect it from season one but with his
character you truly get invested in his
story eventually you see the toll that
job takes on him how much he has to suck
her up and just you know repress all
that [ __ ]
just not deal with it oh yeah it's no
position to express any of it I can't
remember it season three or four I'm
pretty sure it is season four at one
point they make Hank a total [ __ ] to
his wife Marie yeah I called him a [ __ ]
that's what he was being not an [ __ ]
where he's taking his anger and trauma
on his wife like a [ __ ] I'm telling you
that this show challenges you with its
characters the reason why we stay
onboard even when the characters are not
so television like E if that makes sense
if say you don't judge the characters
the writing so good that it just makes
sense for those characters to be that
way at that particular time but Hank
after you know he's done me a [ __ ]
he becomes way more likeable like right
away and he's got the charm you're so
invested in his journey and the class of
him hunting down the kingpin of crystal
meth who happens to be his
brother-in-law just God genius honestly
the character didn't care too much for
was Marie Schrader I never fully
believed her I felt like some part of
her was always acting it was too easy
for me to notice nothing she's a bad
actress she has some truly great moments
some great episodes even and sometimes I
think yeah pull my penis Center
especially in the last season she had
some great moments it was just like the
first tumor was really distracting but
later on she becomes much more
intriguing to watch and that's so cool
tonight to see a character of all
watching actress evolve over time
someone who could win me over because
it's all about pleasing Ryan Wright and
RJ might says Walter White jr. or Flynn
this dude is an incredible actor I heard
in real life he does have a mild case of
cerebral palsy but in the show you know
he had to not like ever up the cerebral
palsy he had to portray even more
because he just had a mild case this guy
had a big case of cerebral palsy I
didn't know till the show was over that
he was acting all that I thought they
hired a kid who really had it that bad
if there's one complaint I had about the
guy it's that he doesn't look anything
like Walter White's or mrs. white but
that's not really his fault I mean you
could have gotten surgery but he's not
committed to the performance like that
and of course the supporting characters
Bob Odenkirk
as saw better call Saul I loved Saul
Saul is one of the most entertaining
people to watch just in general this
actor does a great [ __ ] job and that
there's any performance in this show
that could have been a 2-dimensional
performance it could have been this guy
but man
Agis brings in the life with the sense
of humor the business the the swag that
he's got going on a lot of the
characters don't really trust him or
don't think he's that smart yet in the
audience see you always have faith in
salt and I think the better call Saul
show is going to be [ __ ] awesome
all you got to do is explore his
personal life which we never got to see
so you get that in there and man we got
a show Chuck Bass is my garbage trots
another very human performance they're
all so good something about his
performance tells me that he was only
supposed to be on a few episodes but
then he thought he was so good that they
kept him on for most of the series he's
that former cop now roles were the bad
guys
but he's always cool and collected never
really in a panic you know there's a
sense of like vulnerability and
sincerity but you can also feel like a
bad guy in this dude whatever Mike says
you're gonna [ __ ] do it it's that
simple if mike says suck your own dick
you're gonna figure out a way to do it
I would totally suck my own dick if Mike
asked me Terry
a new kid ever forget Gus fring forgot
the actor's name his first episode when
he burst onto the screen holy [ __ ] we
knew how amazing he was that very moment
if you guys saw the show do you remember
that he's just the regular nice manager
and you totally buy him as this is
regular nice guy and then in that moment
where he just says a sentence you and I
are not to like it all mr. white that
was the first time I tried that
impression and somehow I came out with
Philip Seymour Hoffman he just like
makes this switch to total gang badass
leader he's like the black or Hispanic I
don't know what [ __ ] ethnicity this
guy's version of what Walter White could
be Gestapo free he's just a [ __ ] man
when I think of like ultimate badass
businessman I immediately think of this
guy this guy never loses his cool any
piece about to you're like home then
your heart starts beating really fast
and you get an erection for some reason
I don't know why this guy knows how to
persuade like anyone and if you can't be
persuaded you better look the [ __ ] out
cuz black or Hispanic Walter White is
coming after you like the great thing
about his performance is they barely
give you any background about him they
have like one short flashback with him
but you can feel that the actor knew the
whole history in and out in and out
a better way that's what she said and I
gotta give credit to Jesse Plemons as
Todd he's only in the last season to the
show but man was he great like he comes
across like a total nice charming guy
that you forget all the time that he's a
complete psychopath like so much
sincerity to the role that you'd like
him when he's just being Todd and
emotion I forgot he's massive serial
killer who's fantastic in the role and I
love the antagonistic relationship
informs Jesse the writing of this is so
brilliant because they understand every
elements of the characters being it's
like every writer asks themselves how
should this character be now that this
thing has happened to them they like
think about the whole psychology of it
all they take every factor to
consideration the core of the story is
the characters not you know watching
guys just cook crystal meth and make a
[ __ ] ton of money although that [ __ ] is
cool that [ __ ] makes you want to cook
crystal meth actually makes you want to
try crystal meth - and each season is
its own chapter of this one complete
story think about it if you've seen the
last episode imagine introducing the
last episode of someone as the first
episode they'd be watching just that
episode alone has so much in it that the
people could like make up the history
behind it it creates more mystery to the
elements and then every episode before
the last one feels like a prequel to
that one that you want to see it from
beginning to end because every single
season and episode all ties in like me
watching it I forgot just how different
the characters changed by season 5 like
they're just not the same like the
actions of these people have major cause
and effect the story is not about the
end results it's about the goddamn
journey there's no way I can see this
story being told into a movie and there
are each two and a half hours and it was
a two and a half hour version of that
season and they divided part five into
two parts
I'm talking to you Hollywood this is me
copy writing the Breaking Bad movie idea
and then you get ray winstone as Walter
White and Zac Efron as Jesse Pinkman and
Ed Asner's Hank Schrader
I know casting in every episode was just
directed beautifully whoever their
cinematographer was on that show Wow
sucking his dick it has that realistic
feel about it and it's like slow moving
and there's tension and even though it's
like a rather slow show it's incredibly
gripping the whole time like there's so
many people I meet that watch this show
who I would have never
suspected to watch his show I have met
Asian people who watch this show the
show to me is the best antihero series
I've ever seen I'm sad the show is over
man I miss hanging out with these
characters going on the stages journey
with them it's great to have a series
where each season is strongly important
this show doesn't feel strung out it
just gets more intense as the story
continues and thank God it ended
brilliantly if I have to choose my two
favorite seasons I'll probably choose
like season two because that's what I
felt Walter White was really Breaking
Bad in that one like part one was the
introduction to him Breaking Bad the
part two is when he was no this is him
becoming Walter White that was the real
start of what he became and also in
season two you got hooked into the other
characters more it just it just felt
right it's like it was a perfect
extended version of season one could see
someone this is more introducing the
characters getting you invested in them
season two is when the actual journey of
this [ __ ] really takes off but season
five holy [ __ ] I had so many anxiety
attacks watching this show do you know
means I'm going to masturbate to calm
down during this show let me tell you it
was the easiest thing to masturbate to
try jerking off when people are cooking
meth go ahead put the video on pause
goodie to room injury go how was it yeah
and one of the mid points at the last
half of season five it starts off like
five minutes in there's a shocker moment
I'm here to tell you right now if you
haven't seen the show there's a moment
your jaw is gonna drop five minutes into
one episode
that's how shocking it is the directing
writing acting some of the best I've
ever seen
not just in television but in like all
cinema all around let me get straight to
the point here
all I gotta say Breaking Bad got it
super duper right
alright guys a check none on review for
Breaking Bad why don't you go ahead
school that comment box below and tell
me did use your a golf to crystal meth
and want to see more episodes are
straight to the point you can click
right here watch more of my reviews
watch more of my [ __ ] cuz I did a lot of
videos I'm very self-absorbed last mile
at least you're gonna get up eat it
every time one of my reviews is out
gonna clear on this blog about my dick
to subscribe that's right you subscribe
by clicking the penis that's simple
tell you something little Ryan right
here
he's been ready to break bad for a while
I'm talking fat black chicks Taiwanese
woman and of course hookers with an STD
and now I won't be wearing a condom that
is really breaking man actually
imagining that for myself almost gave me
a heart attack